[Música]
Bienvenidos a esta nueva edición del
programa enlace conosur desde la ciudad
de Río de Janeiro en el que hablaremos
de las elecciones presidenciales y
legislativas de Brasil que se celebran
el próximo 2 de octubre son las más
reñidas desde el fin de la dictadura
militar en 1985 en teoría hay más de 10
candidatos a la presidencia pero solo
dos tienen reales posibilidades de ganar
el actual presidente de Brasil Jair
bolsonaro de 67 años y el ex presidente
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva de 76 años
[Música]
bolsonaro aspira a un segundo mandato
Aunque todos los sondeos le colocan en
el segundo lugar Si gana promete ahondar
en el proceso de privatizaciones de las
empresas públicas y mejorar el acceso de
los ciudadanos a las armas también
pretende dar un impulso la actividad
minera y mejorar la competitividad del
sector Agrario hemos preguntado algunos
electores que esperan de ese hipotético
segundo mandato Y esto es lo que nos han
contado
[Aplausos]
sinceramente
que él continúe con el proyecto que
implantó en el primer mandato con las
temáticas de la defensa de los intereses
de la familia de los intereses de la
patria y de la nación y de la lucha por
la libertad que es lo que vinimos a
hacer hoy aquí
a la libertad que aunque no
estoy segura de que todo lo que
evolucionario no consiguió implementar
en el primer mandato porque muchas cosas
no fueran hechas porque no le dejaron
una de ellas será la reforma de las
pensiones
porque importante es importante porque
necesitamos reformar las pensiones
porque las personas están cada vez más
viejas y necesitan recibir su jubilación
[Aplausos]
el ex presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva es el claro favorito en todos los
sondeos condenado por corrupción y
pasado 580 días en la cárcel de curitiba
Sin embargo el tribunal supremo anuló
todas sus condenas por defecto de forma
y así pudo recuperar su derecho a ser
candidato Si gana esas elecciones
promete erradicar el hambre mejorar la
economía y la imagen de Brasil en el
mundo también prometen fortalecer los
órganos que vigilan la masaria y que
luchan contra la deforestación ilegal en
las tierras indígenas Esto es lo que sus
electores esperan de él
Lula va a ser de nuevo todo lo bueno que
hizo por nosotros eso es lo que espero
de él votaré a Lula en estas elecciones
por la misma razón que agapor nosotros
lo que siempre hizo cuidar del pueblo
renueve toda la educación en Brasil
porque la educación es lo único que
puede encarrilar al país
una buena educación es muy muy necesaria
el 2 de octubre los 156 millones de
lectores brasileños también tendrán que
renovar el congreso y el senado por
primera vez el número de candidatos
negros supera al de los blancos en un
país en el que el 54% de la población se
define afrodescendiente también hay un
número
récord de candidatos indígenas son 178
en total más de 28.000 candidatos
disputan un escaño en el parlamento hay
que recordar que la cámara baja Tiene un
gran peso en un gobernado por un sistema
semipresidencialista eso quedó evidente
en 2016 cuando el congreso aprobó
olimpichment de Dilma roussef la
expectativa para estos comicios es
máxima en un país que está cada vez más
dividido entre la derecha y la izquierda
muchos se preguntan que era bolso de
perder las elecciones entregará el poder
de forma pacífica hay que recordar que
el actual presidente de Brasil se ha
dedicado a descalificar el
funcionamiento del voto electrónico que
hace de Brasil uno de los países más
rápidos del mundo en divulgar los
resultados electorales incluso
evolucionario llegó a convocar a más de
50 Embajadores para criticar el
funcionamiento de las urnas electrónicas
varios analistas políticos temen que Los
Seguidores del presidente provoquen
disturbios callejeros y que traza las
elecciones y lleguen a producirse
escenas de violencia parecidas a las del
Capitolio de Washington en enero de 2021
el 2 de octubre los brasileños también
están llamados a elegir a los
gobernadores de los 27 estados que
componen la federación de Brasil aquí en
Río de Janeiro se enfrentan el
bolsonarista Claudio Castro y el ulista
Marcelo freixó Un conocido defensor de
los Derechos Humanos la gran
protagonista de estas elecciones es la
polarización y para entender este
fenómeno hemos invitado a la politóloga
Marcia Rivero Díaz profesora de la
universidad Federal de Río de Janeiro
como usted explica el fenómeno de la
polarización en Brasil la polarización
la polarización es normal en un
escenario competitivo lo que nos explica
es la radicalización de posturas que
llevan a peleas al punto de que algunos
cometan asesinatos la división en
facciones es un problema mayor cuando
los grupos se comportan no como
adversarios sino como enemigos políticos
y es muy importante que dejemos Clara
una cosa no existe este comportamiento
de dos polos distintos no hay dos grupos
que intentan hay un grupo que intenta
eliminar al otro tengo un grupo otro
factor es la abstención y el voto nulo y
blanco esta fue la elección de 42
millones de brasileños en 2018 es decir
un tercio de todos los electores esa
tendencia viene aumentando en los
últimos años y demuestra La decepción de
la población con sus políticos hasta
aquí enlace econosur desde la ciudad de
Río de Janeiro sobre las elecciones
presidenciales y legislativas de Brasil
yo soy Valeria sacone y en la cámara mi
colega guillerme Acevedo Hasta pronto